Facebook
we are live and welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel good
morning good afternoon good evening
wherever the hell you are in the world
and um we're talking horror movies and
things today but sci-fi crossovers
horror movies the Paranormal
um we've got a few things that we're
going to talk about but before we get
into it
we're with stormy and we're with Bill
house all the way over there so how are
we doing gentlemen
doing well I'm doing well doing well
excellent hey I just need to find the
opening bit which I can't find and found
it
[Music]
let's just checking the Man United score
I wasn't checking the football score
the seasons back next week so you can
start seeing me cry occasionally The
Season's back next week I thought they
were playing this past week
uh I know I've been using friendlies and
then the season properly starts next
week okay so Dortmund wasn't
a real game just a friendly warm-up so
hey Shelly hey Dave hey cyphus guy hey
Bobby hey Harris McCray's this weird
looking fella
um sci-fi Quest Guy Lee Wilcox is in the
house and yeah we are gonna be talking
some of our favorite sci-fi horror movie
crossovers we're going to be asking the
question is Paranormal stuff sometimes
sci-fi we're gonna be talking about some
of the rules what have we learned from
horror movies it's an important question
but before we get stuck in as we usually
do well we've been watching this week's
so stormy how about you sir what you
been watching
hi Laura
so I've been watching a lot of other
worlds strange new worlds I've been
watching them so
hour after hours I'm singing about it
so I saw that uh there was a general
lack of singing on this week's episode
of foundation
weird weird and uh last episode of
foundation was really really cool
um I thoroughly enjoyed it somebody
almost got laid
um and then uh
and and uh you know I've been continuing
on my journey to a re-bing uh sg1
Stargate sg1 and I'm on
Seasons up near the end of season seven
oh okay so you just had like the it's
all been announced to the world and oh
well the world governments and things
well at the last episode was Avenger 2.0
yes good episode
um I've just done a video it comes out
tomorrow oh no I might come back next
weekend I'm trying to do videos for the
um when I'm going on holiday
um so I'm trying to trying to stockpile
some videos but what it is and basically
says that they should have ended sg1
season seven and I make the argument
they should have ended it at season
seven
um they're raw conversation
um I'm wrong
um I'm never wrong
they should have ended at season seven
just you know
well there was a plan the plan was that
they were going to do a cinematic movie
after season seven I feel like the you
just said that the aurai would have been
really I think better honed in in a film
honestly yeah well the aura is not the
most popular villain event which is why
yeah
some people too much of themselves to be
honest
yeah I don't get there nobody ever
Hallows me and I don't get why
um I just want to be hello damn it I
don't know what that means
um I never should have ended
um my ex used to say I was 36 snores
that came from he said I was a viking
earlier and I said I am 36 North
so much
I [__] love an ax
swords are cool swords are great Oh yeah
and when you stab somebody with somebody
goes that's the noise it makes
so um right so how about you
oh Mark how you doing sir
well of course I've been watching
Futurama the first two episodes since
they've been Aaron uh the first episode
was not like super sci-fi oriented it
was more like we're back kind of thing
but now they're getting into the
concepts which I enjoy
um what we do in the shadows is back as
well it's halfway through its season and
it's funny as hell so I'm I'm enjoying
it but then I also
I finished
all that we have and all that we ever
will have of Henry Cavill as geralt of
Rivia
I don't I'm not enjoying it
it's it's not the best it's not the
worst it's not the best it's not the
worst it's not the best
it's just kind of there
I'm waiting for the last couple of
episodes we've still got like two
episodes left didn't we to drop I
thought they were dropping all together
so when I watched the I so I've been if
the episodes have dropped the other day
and I'm like
where's the end
um I don't know this there's two yep
um the last three are well actually I
think the first of the last three are
good I think the the the seventh episode
is it the seventh episode or is it the
sixth episode six six seven eight is
what they released I think yeah so
there's six episodes really really good
seventh episode is like decent but
you're just like get back to the damn
story and then the eighth episode is
like
how are we going to end Henry Cavill
with with this
yeah well it's it's it's still like
Poetic in some ways but like it's
reaches for poeticism instead of being
like let's just tell her the good story
and as
ah it's just frustrating yeah it's just
and I mean and this is the end of the
series they're not coming back with um
anymore because that would be stupid to
get rid of such a massively popular
characters Henry cavill's
um girl and tried to bring in somebody
else so they're not stupid enough to do
that so obviously
and immediately sign it off for two
seasons before they even get one down
the hatch just
no stupid isn't it before they even
decide to look at what this season's
doing numbers wise which it is not doing
well because like most people did not I
didn't realize either when it like you
said I had no idea it was split into two
parts they're like we're gonna do a
bunch of strangers things kind of stuff
and make sure it gets a lot of extra
views no you just cut all your views in
half because you didn't tell people that
was happening and I I like Liam
Hemsworth I like him when the rumor came
out that he might be joining that they
were trying to get him tap him up to
have the Stargate return
um I was like yeah I could see that I
quite like it
it cannot follow
he can't follow um Henry Cavill it's
just not gonna work
but nobody can it's like trying to put
somebody new in The Terminator all you
know I can have a new Terminator movie
and Arnold Schwarzenegger is not going
to be in it we'll all go thank Christ
on the other hand we'll sort of go
he's he's got some big shoes to fill
yeah um
but to be honest they're gonna have I
think they're gonna have to do the two
seasons and stick to it though because
that first season regardless of how good
he is is going to bomb oh yeah
um it was a necessity but they should
have looked at how well this season was
going to do
before they greenlit anything I think
but of course they are that stupid so
yeah
oh yes
um
what are the people so upset with
yeah I hate hate the game don't don't
hate the players
um yeah it's gonna be bad
um so it might be brilliant but it's not
going to be popular but it might
it might win people over that's my point
it could win people over but the first
numbers are not going to be good
season two and three have not been
quality television in my opinion so
going through
um yeah absolutely I've been watching
Stargate Atlantis again um so Stargate
sg1 Atlantis and SGU are on Sky again
over in the UK and um I have to admit
Matthew who is on holiday this week
um did send me music what does this mean
what does it mean that it's back on
Skype and I'm like it just means that
Amazon really really want as many people
impossible to watch it so really don't
worry about it this is what this is what
they've been doing for months now so
they've just got a new deal so um so
yeah we got but I had forgotten that
road index doesn't come into it until
like the third or fourth episode of the
second season I've forgotten that it's
all I threw on watching when's Ronan
coming to it'd be better if Ronan was in
it
completely forgotten
um but it's awesome
you said Stargate Lance I got goosebumps
because it's exciting I got I've got a
bone under the table
um the um do you know one of the things
I've forgotten about Atlantis as well
because it has been a few years since I
watched it that they do quite a few like
double triple episode things so like the
end of season one is a triple episode
they've just said the one where um we
saw
um Kaylee from Firefly become a bug and
then she bites Shepard and then Shepard
becomes a bug in the second part and I
was like these are brilliant damn
episodes man they're really really good
um and I I think I'd forgotten just how
good SGA is
[Music]
um
I'm going to be doing some videos on it
I think because I've forgotten how just
how good it is
um they took what sg1 had and then just
like didn't necessarily dial it up a
notch but just honed it in a notch and
it was just yeah
one thing I liked about it was the the
spirit of international cooperation you
know
and uh it's it's cut you have the
tension of it being the you have the the
military and then answering to somewhat
of a civilian organization
you know and that was it's kind of like
what we were wanting to sometimes see on
Earth with uh sg1
but and so that kind of uh came through
that version of storyline came through
in its whole and so really uh really uh
I really liked it also Rodney McKay man
he I think he really took his character
that that little schmalty character he
had an SG one and he really ran with it
in Atlantis and it was just
top not he really yeah it was like night
and day he was schwartzy and then he was
still from RC but then he was um
um he was emotionally unsure but then he
was caught you know [__] sure about
thing I mean he just had a really
complex character and I really enjoyed
watching every scene he was on
yeah I just just highlight this I I did
do a live yesterday with a shuttle party
show
um lovely guys
um they're all they're all lovely and um
yeah I found out that I was actually
going to be talking to Tripp and Malcolm
from Star Trek Enterprise two minutes
before the damn life
a kind of Star Trek talking back at me
this
is I don't know and you've embarrassed
yourself
and I was trying to be as play as I
could be and then I spoke to the very
very lovely
um Erica De la Rosa at the end and all I
wanted to say was how pretty she was and
they didn't but I was I was a grown up
and sensible about it but um now they're
lovely people over there
um we are going to be getting hopefully
um uh uh Conor and Dominic trip and
Malcolm on the show at some point to
talk about something
um
should I tell people about the
possibility that came up yesterday
should I leave it leave it okay
okay tell me
yes
you've got the messages
yeah you got the message I sent them to
you so we might have I've been
struggling with fabulous leave me alone
in a month we might have something very
very exciting for the Stargate fans
we'll say no more than that at the
moment but if this person agrees oh my
God if you want to see a giggling mess
that is me I'm going to be a giggling
mess but it's um it's incredible that we
have a possibility something very
exciting so yeah
um but you know I've just I've been
since Stargate Atlantis I was literally
watched
the a season and a half in like a week
so it's like it's all I've been watching
um and the wife is just like what
[Music]
um
anything else and Jamie's just one more
episode
yeah yeah yeah
um just just one second
so so what you said earlier about uh
Ronnie McKay could you say that sg1
Rodney walked
so Meredith could run
hmm
maybe maybe so I love things like when
he says the zpm and then when Z p.m and
then oh yeah I love that he's like what
the what
I found it though the video about the
zpl
and then I have several comments going
into zpm you idiot and um and I was like
no
like I was thinking
yeah exactly
um Kerry says she knows what it is
do you know why I know what Zed means
yeah because like I watched way too many
episodes of Top Gear
yeah
you know Jeremy Clarkson you know
rattling off some model of some car it's
today it's a z9000.
and it took me a while but I finally
figured out oh that's what he meant
that's right I remember when I was a kid
and I watched um an advert about the new
Audi Quattro that was coming out that
was built with an aluminum and I thought
my God this aluminum is this magical
lightweight material what if it's a bit
like aluminum
and for years I thought they were two
different things
because it's spelled differently so well
hey you know we're just speaking English
but that's your language not ours
yeah you'll add all the extra letters
and stuff all the time the OU instead of
the O's
and then you swap with S's and it was
very confusing
too much and then there's the French
now we can and then there's the French
oh my God I was so good at English until
I took French only and it just ruined
the entire grammar and spelling and the
only thing I got out of it was just
sweet basil
yeah I actually had a french guy
um I I have an argument with me and he
would not back down and and at one point
he said I'm not I'm not giving up on
this I'm French and that I just once I
stopped laughing
of course you're gonna give up at some
point that's what the french do
I was like talk about like teeing up
about and I'm so like
good dude you are French this is what
you built the Euro tunnel so that if
there is world war three you can get
under the tunnel into London that much
quicker with your hands up
um and I cannot see that went on a
little bit completely unfair completely
stereotypical but yeah the guy made it
up I mean
come on
get out of the park you guys didn't go
full board uh Freedom fries though
no we we never started we have never
lost a war ever and that we didn't
intentionally give up on
the war of independence we were just
like nah can't be awesomest just let him
have it
yeah
um I I saw something that long ago I
said that we the British have had a war
with every country on the planet
um that existed
um at the turn of the century so there's
like new countries from like hundred and
from the 1900s every other country on
the planet we've had a war with at some
point
I was like my God that's
come on they're British
sounds about right
like some little African nation that
nobody's ever heard of as soon as we
heard of them we turned up with a gun
like
we just found you on a map
what have you got something
rules and that ladies and gentlemen is
world history 101 thank you for
attending
literally for everybody
and then now what we do is we get drunk
and we go on holidays to places that we
used to either own or have definitely
invaded at some point or another and we
start fights again
voila
where are you from
um anyway
britons British people what are you
gonna do you gotta love us
we're not talking about
um drunkenness abroad anyway
um Canada has never fought a war surely
I know you helped us
you felt just a couple of times though
so that was nice and back when you um
refilled it as you were told Canada
when did Canada technically separate
from the monarchy or did they ever
technically separate no yeah King is
still head of state yeah they just kind
of were like
yeah
I feel like they're in limbo
limbo they keep the good bits but became
a republic I was like no if you want to
keep reading pay your taxes directly to
us it's like for no reason other than
that there should be a king tax you want
the king that's great pay tax
um but that's what that's what upset you
a lot when you all got old man
um
you know
and that was the worst thing you wasted
perfectly good tea
well yes off the bridge somehow
yeah what are you gonna do next Philippi
I mean just
I'm gonna throw all the biscuits in the
water next
I do yeah
um that's something that US and Canada
have got in touch we apologize about
everything as well
that you invaded and they liberated
themselves then we're gonna go and
attack them
yeah you you I think the Americans at
the moment looked at what the British
Empire didn't were yeah
except we did it better just a tad not
too much
yeah oh God sink
I saw Optimus 70 millimeter last week
that's one thing I should have added in
it and it was amazing to see it tell us
about it
yeah any good
Oppenheimer 70 millimeter hmm
good as an understatement
okay
bombs bombs
uh oh no I'm mixing up with Bobby ah
it's easy that all the barberheimer talk
they're kind of like one movie all put
together
yeah yeah here in Las Cruces I mean it's
like up in high or a month I mean
because you know it all that occurred
just up the road from where I live and
it was just
ever it's on this yeah my grandpappy he
was doing something and something you
know everyone's selling their own
personal family histories concerning the
events around uh the Trinity blast and
it's like
damn
I gotta go check my attic for
radioactive dust now
because usually you know there's all the
places I've lived you know oh yeah you
know Trinity that's far far away and
then now I'm in you know almost in the
Caldera of the trade of the crater so to
speak
and it's just like oh that was yeah
that's literally up the road
from me how long does radiation take to
go away
um
like you're typing we're like both hands
are doing something with both hands then
you're getting itch and like the third
hand comes up everything and scratches
your nose
does that ever happen how's this going
to happen oh yeah I haven't been here
long enough I think for me to to form
the the third entire uh hand I think
that's just a British thing you can
still see because you you glow
um
the British created the bomb but had run
out of everything after second the
Germans yeah the plans were going to
America but yeah we invented it so thank
you you're welcome
um we we invented everything and yeah
really that might be true
um a bunch of the scientists to be fair
We're British
so there were a few I was better say
Killian Murphy is technically British
but Oppenheimer
and there's also a couple of Germans
there's a caviar there's a caviar be
afraid
um
anyway
so
um same with the jet engine we know we
did invent the jet engine that was there
was no thing about we invented the jet
engine
so again you're welcome
um and we invented the
um television you're welcome
um we almost invented the internet not
quite we went to the computer
um so
um basically the world you're welcome
um the the TV was actually invented by
Scottish person but we because he did
something good he's British thing
yeah so horror movies and the Paranormal
the Paranormal we were actually starting
this conversation because there was a
chat in the
um in the con in the con comments
because Shelley our lovely Shelley who
does our Facebook page isn't a big fan
of sci-fi and she still comes and
watches our stupid videos every single
week
um so they were having a conversation is
the Paranormal something she is
interested in really is that is that
sometimes sci-fi
um and I would argue that maybe it is
sometimes but what do you guys think is
is is there a little bit of a crossover
sometimes between movies that are sort
of paranormal and sci-fi or is at least
the you know like
the way the movie's put together
sometimes like stormy like like I guess
we're we're thinking
in the aspect of when you're watching a
horror movie
it's it's not like true science per se
but because they're treating everything
like real and in paranormal films
anything of the sort because they're
treating it like it's a real thing and
they're usually
using some kind of methodical approach
to take out or capture or destroy or
exercise or whatever to the the demons
or the witches whatever's going on
is because they believe it's real and
they're taking methodical approach to it
does that make it science fiction
definitely more fiction but well it's
well any of these movies you know they
quickly in the script they quickly adapt
what the rules are for the supernatural
premise you know people talked about
this uh a couple weeks ago that a
supernatural
was King Modi in terms of this I mean
they had a certain set of rules that the
world the the world creation abided by
and he did it very well but I wouldn't
really call Supernatural
uh science fiction
you know because I mean it was its own
kind of horror terror you know uh kind
of uh thing but there are some I think
examples of that where you do have
really amazing crossover between
horror Supernatural and science fiction
and I think the best example of that is
X-Files
hey that's yeah yeah that's a great
great example because it was all blended
into one thing the supernatural the way
the writers had it that the supernatural
was the technology it was the creepiness
it was the the cover-ups by the
government it was the cover-ups by the
church in some in some episodes you know
and it they
um Chris Carter man had that down pat he
knew how to write those shows
that's a good point when there was
definitely a crossover between the two I
mean I would argue things like
I know it's a comedy but even like
Ghostbusters
it was paranormal they created it in a
scientific way but even things like The
Conjuring and stuff like that where they
investigated or Poltergeist or something
like that they investigated it but
they used science yeah you know um all
those nonsense TV shows
uh Bob said Kolchak and he's exactly
right he was a lot of Science Fiction a
lot of the horrors one episode when I
think it was a hospital that was built
on an Indian burial ground outside of
Chicago
and to capture this freaked me out as a
kid I mean it is just like oh my God
so Cole Shack got a bunch of uh
uh x-ray film and just made this just
plastered across the wall to get a image
of the uh whatever it was and the only
thing you see is this really old wisened
weathered eyeball
and I had nightmares over that damn
eyeball for months
koshak The Night Stalker the original
[Music]
I don't remember culture
so what was it about was it like a
weekly
yeah it was a kind of weekly monster of
the week it was cold Shack he was a
reporter for a newspaper in Chicago
and the police were covering up all of
these really strange
um occurrences
uh that turned out to be Supernatural
and kolshak his main beat was uh trying
to uncover all of this and he collected
all this this data all these all these
photos all these eyewitness accounts and
the public you know his newspaper
publisher would never publish them and
of course then the uh the uh police
department got off scott fried didn't
have to really explain what was going on
to the public so there's this cover-up
thing going on there was the corporate
oppression of the newspaper and you know
kolshack was like this
um
uh this uh First Amendment freedom
fighter kind of trying to expose all
this and warn the people what was really
going on
it was just called nice Walker over here
they didn't call it call check they
called it Night Stalker
be something
17.75 I think okay
but um yeah related the night Strangler
the night story The Night Stalker yeah
just while you were explaining that it
made me think would Stargate technically
fit in that same bill sometimes with the
ascending and whenever they do do scary
things I guess like Anubis and sometimes
like the the I mean because the gold are
essentially possessing people in a way
so that's demonic in a certain way as
well I guess well I mean
I mean they used a lot look at the the
you used a lot of mythologies to tell
the story I mean there was Thor's race
there's all the Egypt egyptology stuff
that was the very basis of the very
first movie uh-huh Laura just made a
good point she said SGA would for sure
because of space vampires yes basement
wires right right base vampires yeah
like pit of fire demons or whatever and
I think I think you know you could uh
fairly say that
um
for for me it was
[Music]
I think I think the the I don't really
know what I'm trying to say
it was
it's very asmovian you know it's like
you know you get to a point to where if
science is sophisticated enough I've got
to Google that word Asimov Isaac Asimov
asmovian yeah so anyway
um you know as you know Isaac Asimov
said you know any any uh Society with
this technologically advanced enough
their technology looks like magic and I
think that's definitely here because we
you know it's the Soviet Universe we're
always up against
you know a technology that was just what
the hell that's got to be magic and even
some of the cultures that Daniel Jackson
visited had enamored with magic yeah
magic and it was just technology like
that one that I can't remember uh maybe
season four season five uh he had this
it was this preacher guy he had this
little thing ring or whatever and it's
like Zapped the uh the crew and it was
it was gonna be burned at stake or
whatever and it was just the villagers
thought it was magic it was religious
technology
the the same thing when an SGA whenever
they found that other Atlantis site and
they were kind of like using the drones
as their magic protective kind of force
field and all that and it was like that
feudal system kind of thing
which was awesome
a little sci-fi fantasy mixed in with
horror and I mean there's a lot of
Supernatural stuff with the whole thing
with the ancient so because I mean there
was we saw evidence in SGA though that
there was actually a technological
element to them trying to ascend
and we saw hints of that at least
although other than that though it was
very
spiritual
yeah yes very nice um and it was
supposed to be about you know you know
finding that highest sense of being
um and Su on the Crystal Skull episode
and things like that yeah definitely
um
forgot about that one yeah yeah yeah
technically with his uh grandfather
right
um but also I mean you could argue that
lots of things are
um like vampires they're not I've always
assumed that they were genetically
different so they're a preacher who is
it Supernatural is it or could you
actually argue that
I mean what's the difference between a
vampire movie being say Frankenstein
so yeah it's just it's just a different
sort of monster is it
the biggest difference there I think is
because the vampires had much better
clothing sense much better than fashion
sense oh my gosh
I mean Frankenstein he was just you know
you know wearing his hand-me-down
clothes that was stitched together from
like the skins of three Farmers or some
[__] like that I don't know but Dracula
he had a tailor
oh he did if anything he wasn't counting
he he lucked out
um Gary Oldman by the way I thought was
the best
well better than Christopher Lee
as Dracula oh like he never played
Dracula horror movies Chris really
played Dracula
I know he played always played um thingy
swell but I'm sure he played Jacker at
least once he but you know did did Peter
Cushing play Dracula and Christopher Lee
not in one movie played Dracula and
Peter Cushing played
in my head
yeah I think so but I mean Pete Cushing
I think played Dracula at least once and
because I know and I know they either
did opposite because I think Cushing
might have done Dracula and then okay
that's okay that yeah that's not nice
for Roger yeah yeah yeah
um and then I think
and then and then there's um him getting
ready to dance
Gary Oldman had such a unique take on
Dracula yeah that is one of my favorite
portrayals because everyone else was
kind of playing at the same you know
um Oldman just took it completely
different and of course Coppola is the
director really off into a different
direction the
only thing that really bothered me was
Kiana's accent just wanted to strangle
somebody but not the best
pizza Cushing is Dracula as well there
you go
love it all gone blue you know
um
the reason why I like that movie though
is it was
it was one of the first times that that
whole Bram Stoker's Dracula movie with
um uh with his whose name was just come
out my head
um is that I mean other than Keanu
Reeves who isn't the greatest actor in
history but even he was quite good in
that and it was kind of sexy it was kind
of dramatic it was
it was one of those movies that was just
like paced beautifully and edited
beautifully but it was something and it
was but modern and it was they just got
the tone of everything just absolutely
it's one of those films that is
considered a modern classic and
rightfully so because yeah acting was
perfect it got the tone because it felt
a bit hammer horroring in places but
yeah places
um
I would argue is the perfect vampire
movie except maybe
interview the vampire I thought was
was again was one of those films that's
something like an instant classic it was
just phenomenal and I saw Renfield
literally last week you saw it and loved
it really good good good good
I lowered your expectations just enough
to really enjoy it that's good email me
the stick note and I will check that
it's authentic TQ thank you
um we do not tolerate lateness or
whatever it turns up for 30 seconds
before the video starts every damn week
um and you were late that once as well
you just didn't turn it up
and you're like 10 minutes late it's not
good enough
um Vampire in Brooklyn hmm
I'm not so sure on that one I don't even
ever saw it uh it's that is the one with
them
um
the person whose name I forgot see how
good it was yeah
um right Eddie Murphy Eddie Murphy
that's the Eddie Murphy one right it's a
Wes Craven movie
okay now I know I didn't see it
Angela Bassett what the hell is this
yeah Angela Bassett was in it yeah she
played the uh his like girlfriends no
I'm not I was never I'm actually fan of
Vampire in Brooklyn I wanted to sick is
the right one I'm not a massive fan of
that
um
just looking at the pictures it's
amazing
I apologize I mean it happened to me
once it's a nuisance but these things
happen sometimes there's a there's a
movie there's a movie Vampire since
we're talking vampires it was a vampire
movie I really want to uh talk about
and it's called immortal it was a play
on um
it was a play on addiction really
um when it starts out with there's this
uh band and the lead singer you know you
think he's got a heroin addiction you
know he's got the most enabling [__]
girlfriend in the world you know helping
him with his crises and
um
well she's not really trying to buy a
heroin for him or get him to rehab she's
helping hide the bodies
heroin he's addicted to blood because
he's a vampire
hunger it's very hard to find you can
only find like copies of the DVD on eBay
and I would hopefully everybody will
find a copy and watch it because I was
the executive producer
it deserves its three star ratings
I think you've got three stars
the the soundtrack made tons of money
the movie not so much the soundtrack was
really cool
and my head gets torn off who's in the
accident your head got to turn off yeah
I was this heroin junkie that I got
attacked and I had this really cool
um a trench coat with these syringes in
it and it like these certain these
syringes were stitched in to give me
epaulets and like there's this caduceus
on the back of the jacket that was in
shape made up with thin wrenches it was
awesome
what was this called again immortal
just Immortal you if you point me in the
direction or if anybody in the comments
can point me to the direction of
immortal starring stormy
um I will pay real money for it and then
once I've watched it I will give it away
as a prize and it will be The Greatest
Prize you've ever received
um so and guys we as the community we
now have to start searching for this
downtown right I need it in my life what
what year was it do you remember yeah 90
1967. no I was gonna say how old are you
stormy
so let's go easiest way to find it was
uh
1995. oh it's up to 4.4 stars now on in
on on IMDb
[__] sake right straight up I didn't
know this is where this conversation was
going but I am going straight to Amazon
I'm putting the link in uh
oh yeah I'm trying to find the IMDb
portal 1995.
DVD
dextrax yeah it was awesome
Immortal Beloved nope The Immortal no
more director's cut
um
trying to have a look no it's like 30
quid Dex blood and rock and roll That's
it man decks blood and rock and roll
Jimmy put uh look down there I think
you're the only one that could bring it
up uh
I just put her down here
okay yeah this is the IMDB all right
okay
4.4 out of 10. amazing it's going up we
had it down to one at one point
costs 30 quid on Amazon
10 out of 10 for stormy or 150 quid
well you know I'm serious you know it's
uh it used to be three dollars on Amazon
or Ebay and for some reason now it's
it's hundreds of dollars to get a DVD
copy because it's out of print and it
was this really schlocky thing but it
was lots of fun to film
oh my God
dollars on it
yeah oh Salem slot that was a great
movie
brilliant I was thinking about that the
other day actually because um that the
actor and they played the butler scared
the crap out of me
um oh so what have we done now we're all
over the place now is that it no
uh that one I don't know what's going on
um but oh my God I did not know that we
were going that way how much is a quid
at a pound
sir or a dollar about about 80P or
something
um Transformers IMDb credit on here
yeah
yeah I did yeah I used to I started out
you know doing extra work in North
Carolina
and it was I was always trying to get
like playing some sort of a speaking job
but I never could so I decided Well I'll
just start doing stuff behind the lens
because those jobs are much easier and I
got the special effects and special
effects horror like special effects in
Chesterfield or just Cameron electrical
department on Tecumseh yeah
yeah we found his IMDb Pedro
you got him
um
a bio
how much of it is right
oh is there a bio he was born May 5th 63
in Winston-Salem North Carolina US is an
actor and producer known for
Chesterfield Immortal and clean up in
all five
hey I won South by Southwest with
cleanup on aisle five it was a short
yeah oh yeah it's some place on
um YouTube I think cleanup on Alpha oh
cool
to YouTube
oh my God I'm so so excited clean up on
R5
I know what I'm doing first today anyway
I'm watching
um
there's a copy of immortal on eBay for
3.77
I've added you to my keep an eye out
List
complete complete with case
oh my God
right so Immortal DVD Immortal oh my God
that's a sponsored ad who the [__]
doing that
[Laughter]
DVD link is in the description y'all or
in the chat live chat
yeah we are I will find a copy God damn
it
um but hey stormy Bear My Lord here we
go there you go that's we've got the
thing everybody go and buy a copy
somebody's gonna freak the [__] out now
all of a sudden if like 50 people go and
buy a DVD
that'd be amazing yeah my residuals were
done I don't get anything out of that
anymore
I think I got two residual checks and
then that was it
ah damn it you're gonna get like a 30
Cent check in the mail in like two
months and just
smile yeah yeah it's cool this postage
will be more than what the check is
worth
I I did um I can't talk about it too
much but I did a thing a little while
ago and I kept getting a residual check
but for about five years they kept
sending me zero dollars and zero cents
like five years they kept sending me and
then said just stop it just makes me sad
every time I got it every time I got the
check it just makes me sad
um
so
um have you seen the size of that like
button yes we have do you guys in
England still have pennies yes we do we
attracted those in circulation years ago
here in Canada legit asking yes we do
and we have 100 pennies or Pence and
pounds
um and then
um that's it but we call them quid and
we call pennies coppers
so there you go you're learning
something every day and there's
absolutely no copper in them whatsoever
that was that was my next question
none
um but they are Batman great question
have you seen the size of the like
button
if you would press the like button and
also like And subscribe and share the
video wherever the hell you'd like we
love that and the like button is
important hell press the down button it
still gets a click on on YouTube but but
don't because it makes me sad whenever I
put a new video out there are people
that subscribe to my channel the weirdly
don't like the channel I don't know why
but I will put a video on and within two
minutes before anybody's watched it
there'll be a down thumb
so some idiot then subscribe to the
channel and hit the Bell notification
just so when I put a video on I can hit
the download
that's dedication they got dedication oh
idiotic as long as that algorithm click
is there yeah
hell yes yeah yeah that that's the thing
that moves you're still helping me so
why do you do it it's just like don't
get it but it makes me smile every time
I say it so horror movies paranormal
movies that I don't think what are the
sort of films we're talking about I've
got the sofa are there any modern ones
of this sort of variation that you guys
have liked because I tell you what I saw
with life not long ago and that was sort
of like that's a horror movie but it is
sci-fi because it's a little alien
organization it had Ryan Reynolds and
Jake Gyllenhaal and somebody else in it
yeah when you just said that it rang a
bell that there was a little bit of
Supernatural element in Battlestar
Galactica
yeah who what was started
Supernatural definitely spiritual yeah
well you know like who who was in the
Viper you know in in what was Starbuck
at the end
yeah
do you know what mate I might have
stopped watching about zygalactic
towards the end
are you all about the original Batman
cygalactica knew better the more nice it
was David B what's Rebecca Ferguson
you're right um oh she's lovely and it's
such a good film if you haven't watched
life with Ryan Reynolds Rebecca folks in
the go watch it the end is stunning it's
I just Googled it I don't know it was a
thing I'm gonna have to watch that one
it's amazing I think it's on Netflix
here in the UK
um so oh my God
but you know I think if there was a
technology
a science fiction
in Supernatural ultimate
singular crossover it would have to have
been Hellraiser no I'm thinking it have
to been The Simpsons Halloween episode
with X-Files
when they have uh
I think that's the ultimate that you
can't go any harder than that no pun
intended
but think about it I don't know if you
guys remembered or even saw it but you
know it had you know Dana and Dana
Scully and um Fox Mulder you know doing
some sort of investigation and and it
was a Halloween episode if I Boop oh
and I can't hear a word he's saying he
said he's gonna I bet he's got to go pee
I bet he's gonna go pee
because we've talked to him
[Laughter]
like that one was great
but no it was a it was a Halloween
episode and they were trying to solve
what some sort of ghost thing I believe
or maybe just been just a crossover
episode anyway
it's really good but I remember uh Fox
Mulder had um
Homer on the treadmill doing some sort
of experiment and scully's saying well
you know what's the purpose of this he
says oh I just like to watch his fat
jiggle it's quite mesmerizing
I love The Simpsons
right I mean it's just like a mill you
know a million of seasons ago too it was
just it was really good
the I I I think I've seen that episode I
just don't remember I I remember the
dude from X-Files being turned into the
Simpsons though and and being like the
little character I just don't remember
anything about the episode
my favorite thing The Simpsons have ever
done and probably my favorite thing they
ever will do though is The Simpsons
Movie it is absolutely perfect in every
way Spider Pig Spider Pig
I love spider pig
it was not pertinent to you know
the witch thing
uh Cat Bus
but it's not pertinent to the census
Studio Ghibli
my neighbor totally yeah
anybody else in the chat room Totoro is
or am I just
I I have not seen cat bus but I've seen
Totoro uh Studio ghibli's amazing in
Totoro if this is the Totoro standing
where the leaf over his head and he's
waiting on the cat bus to go to take him
someplace yeah
okay well I'm not controlling this
conversation very well because it is
wandering all over the damn place
oh you left we had the best time ever
but uh one one comment that was made
like before you left uh and while we
were talking about that was stranger
things is probably the perfect example
of what we're talking about and now
we're thinking about it yeah yeah
yeah it is that Perfect Blend isn't it
that it is it is science fiction but
it's also Supernatural and it's a
monster movie and
um there's all sorts of ground but that
is that is it is sci-fi really it's very
much
um and it's probably
populist TV shows in the last 10 years
so yeah for the amount of people
my favorite scene is on the roof of that
building in in the playing the game oh
my God it was the most metal thing I
have ever seen that was so cool it was
like so many albums
man it was just awesome you built
relationships for a living and you can
never be as cool
is also
it would be getting into rumored
territory and there's not there's it's
not for sure anything but on the
interwebs on the twitters or X whatever
the hell it is nowadays
could they please do that with their
logo I'd Die uh uh
Instagram
through the chat members they know
what's going on we're just I don't know
where we have drifted so far
I don't know
I'm asking them there was something on
something on Twitter
Twitter
no oh okay we were talking about
stranger things I was like I know it's
something to do with stranger things
Jonas Quinn the guy that did the the
metal guitar riff may be the new uh uh
uh Johnny Storm the Human Torch for
Fantastic Four great oh okay great
I I quite like that I didn't feel there
was um a Matt Smith possibly as
um
as as I almost said as Matt Richards as
Reed Richards as
I don't know I started saying Adam
Driver and I just want Adam Driver now
so bad
um
Adam Driver I mean commercially just
like Adam's drivers you're just
affordable chilling in the basement he
said apparently Matt is out that's
probably not a bad thing to be honest
um I'm not sure about Adam's driver
though
but he has got a cool voice right yes
yeah yeah and he can come off that smart
he can come off as like the most
intellectual individual in the the
Multiverse and all that kind of stuff
you know
[Music]
um
no no no I don't know Aaron would know
more about that chill in the basement
would know more about all that uh I I
try to stay in
into some updates but who knows the
world's big rumors went there that we
were going to have a Mrs thing rather
than a Mr thing and they'll do I I think
they'd be insane to mess with it don't
know if they've tried to do that sort of
thing and they've always burn their
fingers Disney need to be so freaking
careful about what they do now if
they're gonna change stuff the the the I
don't even like talking about it because
I want them to hire me one day and
talking about rumors for Disney is
Troublesome territory but uh that is the
thing they went I think it was Mila
Kunis David Diggs and then now uh
supposedly they're looking for a an
overweight white dude they want a fat
white dude to play the thing which is
like okay makes sense are you Jewish
though I think you got to be Jewish you
gotta have the full full like
the years I went to synagogue for two
years does that count there you go
honestly
if you're trying to have sex with
somebody at the synagogue
oh I wonder how that happened you know I
said somebody as well because I'm not
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna push you
into a into a pigeon hole here sir
um but uh uh I've I I've got the nose
for it so I think I could go for it I
could pretend like a little paper
the Sci-Fi Quest you know gave me an
idea has Disney really done a good
supernatural horror movie do they have I
mean is that in their tradition
I mean maybe Touchstone yeah but
I said Dumbo that's no no that's not um
creepy clown stuff in there it's some
psychedelic trippy stuff but I don't
wouldn't say It's Supernatural
back in the day back in the 60s and 70s
doesn't count which mountain doesn't
count
I know the director for that one
um
Disney and Supernatural White movie uh
that's Snow White movie they're gonna
they were talking about that last week
when they the the director and that's
we're talking about it and they're
saying now she's not going to be a um
she's not she's not gonna need men she's
not gonna be kissed and survive and all
that sort of thing and oh yeah and I'm
like well it's not Snow White then so I
mean that's the story okay how are you
gonna and the the couple of the
actresses we're talking about now on the
red carpet when they're going yeah she's
not gonna need no man
it sounds like it's going to be a bloody
mix match of God knows what so yeah it
could be it could be horrific mess that
I try and stay away from Disney
um I I know
um somebody that works in and around
that area and they tell me a few things
here and there and you really can't tell
what's nonsense and what's made up
because all of the rooms that come out
of it are just stupid
um if they did any the biggest example I
think of Supernatural for Disney these
days would be Star Wars in the force
um I mean that says you know
no I might tricks and everything yeah
there were things in the blood they said
so on that one movie that I'm not
allowed to discuss anymore because Star
Wars fans have decided they don't want
to get the prequel movies
so
[Music]
um that's not spiritual
um science but it is though uh George
Lucas had a really great description of
it uh I think Star Wars Theory made a
video about it like a couple like a
month ago uh George Lucas had a really
really good description of it and I I
can't think of it for the life of me
right now but
if you find that video it's great it's
good to hear from a horse's mouth you
know
well all I say is that yeah that I mean
that was they create a religion around
it so they call it religion repeatedly
so then yeah spiritual Isn't So
spiritual even if they try to pretend
there's some sort of scientific reason
for the force it's it's but you can't
forget religion-led science for
millennia
yeah look at that one the Dark Ages when
it didn't go great I didn't say it went
great but they did it it's so bad that
all the scientists and mathematicians
moved to Baghdad did was there an order
66 in real life that we just don't know
about from back in the day whether
religion just wiped out of like a good
chunk of things well probably not order
66 because most people couldn't count
the 66 back in those days that's true
the Crusades were ordered 22 or
something
yeah
was it the um the Spanish Inquisition
no talks about the Spanish Inquisition
right
um but yeah never know so what what
let's let's go back to the Sci-Fi thing
that we were talking about then so what
films
what are some of the good examples of
those films though because I said I I
think like back there the fly was for me
was just a really sci-fi horror movie
um but
it was great how about some other ones
the original alien
oh yeah intense Thriller as well I mean
psychological Thriller I think once uh
Cameron got a hold of it for aliens it
turned more into an action movie as
opposed to a horror movie
so I just I can't shout out to Captain
Cave Man again
you're welcome
um oh yacht Cruiser we will see you in a
month we will not be live by the way
guys for the next two Saturday uh
Sundays because I'm not here
oh no
yes two I'm not here for two so we will
be back at the end of August as well
um
I'm going to try if I've got time to set
up some best of videos for
the next couple of Sundays though so I'm
going to dig out some Best of You bits
from the last 12 months or so and um and
then yeah we're gonna
I'll put them on instead so find your
favorite Side Track clips and comment
them in this video to help Jamie out we
need a clip collection of just Jamie you
know with with uh like Drake in his
mouth trying to not shoot it out of his
nose after I've uh
but last week we started talking about
butt plugs and you couldn't talk for
about 10 minutes
but there's something that both of you
need to watch right now so
no no no no no no no it's it's great no
it is 22 minutes that you will not
regret
um have you ever watched It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia the What It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia
I've seen a couple episodes Danny
Gandolf himself uh Danny DeVito
just is is my freaking spirit animal
it's the
Danny Danny DeVito tickle your elbow out
every time uh
uh so that I would preface this episode
real fast
have you or do you stay any up to date
in the Chess World at all or have you
heard any big International chess news
in the last year
Queen's Gambit I watched that okay
that's okay that's the last thing most
people have heard of last year there was
a big thing Magnus Carlson the big chess
dude that was like
uh winning and stuff he got beat by this
one guy and then this one guy kept
beating a bunch of other like
Grand Masters and things like that and
he was a very low leveled kind of guy
uh
so people put a theory together online
after watching like the videos back and
and like of the tournaments and
everything and they were like
something's up with this guy's face kind
of deal
so the theory was
well okay let me let me let me say this
sentence before I finish the series now
before any professional chess match
there has to be a cavity search because
apparently
the vibrating butt plug that was
played from somebody else from afar
could tell him which way to but put the
chess piece
and and this is where the It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia episode comes in
Danny DeVito the time the episode is
it's the newest season that just
finished up it's called Frank versus
Russia it's Frank Danny DeVito's
character versus a Russian Grandmaster
in chess and they are controlling him
through a similar situation and it is
the funniest 20 minutes that you will
have all week
somewhere in there there's a sentient
anus joke but I can't think of it right
now
the alien book plug and it looks like an
alien from the movie with Sigourney
Weaver and then uh
immediately Googled that
that's a brave bit of Google in there so
um my wife
doesn't check my instant history but if
she did yeah
um hey Bubba Franks how you doing sir a
remote control butt plug a real thing
apparently 50 Shades could have been so
much better yeah
um
right okay
screw the screw what we were talking
about
I give up
what is wrong with people
yeah there's a lawsuit over the loss
there's there's like legit International
lawsuits going on over electronic butt
plugs and chess there you before
professional chess matches nowadays you
have to have a cavity search and that is
just the funniest Factor can you imagine
these old guys you know from back in the
old country with their strollers getting
you know their walkers going up and just
like what all you do is walk up there's
a guy with the blue gloves just going
oh you want to play chess
bend over oh
I'll play checkers
I'm now the world's czechers
there can be cavity searches in chess
now
um
Batman said some things are the best
left ungoogled no I gotta Google right
now
yes
cavity oh God I can hear the glove snap
s
chess cavity
chess game cavity shirts
okay U.S Chess Championship checking for
silicon devices apparently are they are
they just checking that one dude
well if he does it there's got to be a
dozen other people that have tried it by
now which is just bad to think about it
it would seem like that would really
ruin your concentration on the game that
you got to concentrate so much on your
thinking oh you need to watch the Frank
versus Russia episode so bad it's so bad
the the best my I literally like cried
laughing at yesterday laughing at it
yesterday it was just so great
the the instant that he first feels it
he's he said the facial reaction from
Danny DeVille is amazing it's just he's
putting the chess piece forward and goes
oh
and then they're just interested
and yet another episode of Sidetrack
live that has been demonetized
we haven't got that yet because nobody's
nobody's got colorful language I wonder
if there's this thing is haunted butt
plugs can you get a haunted butt plug
but that'd be really interesting Shelly
just left but she's good at putting
items at ghost in items so we need to
ask Shelley if that was an opportunity
every something cool to auction off is a
haunted butt plug
you know for uh have been murdered by
the butt plug or something to
I mean
well do you have to be murdered by plugs
for it to be haunted being a haunted
butt plug thing
um I can I I can feel
subscribers literally just disappearing
off and yeah you probably got so many
downvotes right now oops
um um stranger things
one thing we were going to ask is what
other what are them what what have we
learned from horror movies oh
um
what have we learned
stay away from the change
interesting yeah stay away from the
chainsaw Barn that's the biggest lesson
for a while if you go if anybody's got
one of those you know like those
Choppers the chop wood and stuff don't
go running around it and playing away
from those
um versus evil
yeah
um it's one of those plastic Talent too
they add it again
um David Bailey's coming
Sidetrack your social honest reviews of
butt plugs in society
just generally we're doing our civic
duty here what do you mean we're humor
advice consumer advice
um
Megan two the bud blog oh no oh no the
AI butt plug coming to life
Megan the butt plug
um leg three can you take it
so
no seriously calm down don't say putt
plug no no butt plug
um let's talk about dildos for a bit no
more joking I can't do that either
um
my
um partner who I lived at the time
wanted to put the a dido rail in you
know like that wall and I miss herder I
thought she said she was going out to
the hardware store to buy a dildo and I
was still like rail a dildo Rail and my
first genuine thought was how big is it
but that was because I meant yeah I
didn't know anything but yeah rules then
we've moved from horror movies I I
learned that if something weird is
happening just run away
all those things about side of the pool
walk don't run walk don't run [__]
run run away yeah
um if you come to a house at the end of
the road and the lights are not on do
not knock on the front door
[Music]
there you go you're welcome leave them a
bag of treats where's the pooping
[Music]
if you're having meatloaf for dinner do
not eat it at the Haunted Mansion
no and and particularly gone missing
they hate me somebody's gone missing and
then they serve up Meatloaf
unless the person that's gone missing
you didn't like them very much in which
case if it tastes like pork yeah
yeah pick out like a toenail
um extra collagen healthy for you right
yeah exactly
um I think I think horror movies have
taught us a lot though over the years
um Sci-Fi movies have as well if you're
wearing a red jumper and so what weird's
gonna happen you're definitely gonna die
first yeah don't do that
um
what else go in the comments what else
have we learn from sci-fi and horror
movies over the years I generally just
think that if anything weird happens my
German Village just run away or kill it
uh stay away from the black hole if
you're on shrooms just saying yeah you
got me with
um
I would generally argue if anybody that
you know acts a bit weirdly just kill
them yeah because generally speaking of
over being like in like something's took
over their bodies or there's like an
alien in their skull or we learned this
from Stars don't wait for their eyes to
Glow kill them first yep so if you're in
a situation and you're on a spaceship
and you got that one kind of
a little bit crazy dude and he's always
sharping his big Bowie knife he's either
a going to kill everybody on board or B
he's going to save everybody on board
there is no in between he's either going
to kill you or keep you from being
killed with his big ass Bowie knife
that's really really sharp see the only
problem with this is from what I've
learned from movies is I'm killing the
guy with a Bowie knife first so if he is
there to save us
we're kind of screwed because I've
already murdered him yeah why Bowie
knives are the best you can always truck
though ain't people yeah but then my
thing is I will then take the Bowie
knife and then anybody else that's ever
seen a horror movie I'm then the Target
and then they're gonna think oh there's
the crazy guy with the Bowie knife we
get to go kill him yeah I know which is
the problem the Bowie knife becomes
cursed literally just stand behind
though in that guy yeah but luckily
though I'm so pretty that I Will Survive
the horror movie because the pretty guy
always always survives don't he and you
know
survive
the pretty girls die pretty instantly
it's like pretty girls and like the
black guy they always die almost
immediately well it's either like the
black dude or like the pretty girl and
pretty guy that are are usually having
sex in the beginning of the film that's
your first people that always died yeah
don't have sex
on marriage so I don't that's not an
issue
um out of the three of us in a horror
movie who dies first
sorry Harris
survive
I think you're the most likely to have
sex
um and you're the most likely I I I I I
don't know you obviously I only know you
from this but I'm pretty sure I could
kill you if I needed to
so I I don't know I think stormy I think
he'd bite you
I think you'd be and imagine there was
no hesitation there is an absolutely
nothing I think he would cheat the [__]
you'd go down sweetie all right so I'm
pretty sure I could you know I'm making
it what I'm doing is I'm getting all the
food putting in an escape pod and then
just leaving that's me
yeah I wouldn't even be in this
situation because I'd be gone
you just see me running over the hill
here we go the comments know best of
course
I'm pretty sure I'd have killed Harris
and then you would think you would think
I was dead and then I popped back up
yeah or I'm the killer because you think
I'm dead but I'm actually the Killer
but you're actually the killer I like
playing villains I want to play some
villains they're fun they're the most
fun things to do I'm the guy in the
corner going what's going on someone
going on what's Happening
what where'd Susan go and uh I'm the guy
in the corners no freaking clue what's
going on and then I'll slip in some
blood oh bloody
somebody's left and right a mess
Edward foot is this yeah Jay with his
broken beer bottle
tell you what Kayla said okay I wouldn't
kill anybody unless you know that movie
within the airplane it lands uh alive
was it alive
could you eat a loved one remember oh
yeah
to die
two kids were just like
or
one of my children died in the crash I'd
be chewing on their [__]
by lunchtime that they'll the rescue
mission will fly in four hours after
we've crashed and I'll be on my third
dead body I am yeah no problem with it
at all
I'm hoping the fat guy dies so I can get
a nice bit of crackling it'd be um
I I generally wouldn't bother me in the
slightest but I am a manager drank my
own piss a lot
I mean even when I wasn't made to I
don't remember this a few times so it's
just it's hard not to it's hard time I
was made to it was like it was survival
stuff you were you just said you were
not made to and you drank it still once
or twice by accident accident yeah Bill
hazing
what's the problem with drinking your
own it's not a problem I've drunk other
people's once or twice that's not
surprising what did they teach you on
Britain you and Bear Grylls what what
the hell is going on
how did this conversation turn to
foreign
yeah I just don't have a problem
um it's I barely anything
but we had I was in Saudi Arabia and we
got fed monkey and um and there was oh
God you can't it's monkey and I'm like
what that's [__] it was lovely and
the only thing I've ever eaten that I
regret was I was up in up right up in
North Scotland and we had Puffin and
it's disgusting it's awful horrible
thing it's like eating leather
um it's oh it's horrible the specialty
thing with the wings and it's slimy and
it's it's just nasty
um uh but I'll eat pretty much anything
else
I don't know I got this subject either
well
there's been butt plugs and there's been
dragging your own pee it's just been
been an interesting
and Puffin eating Puffin yeah puffing
culinary Deluxe you you guys must have
met at some mental [__] in America okay
so they might like crocodiles lovely and
and um I've eaten a penguin as well
wait say penguin real quick chocolate
bar penguin
oh that sounds interesting uh no you
just said pink one and you made me think
of uh you don't say it like it but uh
Benedict Cumberbatch have you ever heard
him say the word penguin oh God bless
his heart yeah it's the funniest thing
he says penguin penguin penguin
I I just I was thinking it's funny
whenever I got to America and somebody
will say ask me if I'm Australian and I
just that just cracks me up every single
time like no I'm very clearly British
but we have such various accents you
know like the scouse accent is you have
to be drunk to understand anybody for
Liverpool
man [__] another [__] thing and
it's just like I'm sorry
there is a an American accent that's
very
um tied in with the uh with the
Liverpool accent and that's uh the
Appalachian accent
some people think in southern but it's
really not it's tied in it's it's really
uh culturally and from ancestrally uh
from that area in UK
Appalachian accent look it up he's right
I remember a guy came up to me in
Liverpool once again
hello mate where are you from all
talking lady
and and I couldn't
um England what the [__] are you from
but I'm terrible that I get I get accent
here and I I copy people's accents so
when I was in America I started seeing
coffee and I don't know like we're in
New York and I've started saying I I can
have a coffee and my mates took a piss
out and it's not bad but in Liverpool
I I had a few beers and I started I
started [__] talking at the back of
my mouth like this but then other
scousers thought I was taking the piss
out of them and if there's a race of
people you don't want them to think
you're taking the piss out of them it's
the scouse because they will kill you
and they will kill your children and
your children's children that they're
not they're not a race of people you
want to annoy who are the scouts I was
just like who the hell are the scouts
what is the scouse people from Liverpool
are called scousers oh oh I thought he's
like scowling Scots or something was
this you know Scottish
the most ferocious group of people in a
13 square kilometer region yeah they're
vicious
um and they'll rob you Blanc I'm sorry
it's a too small to be scary
but they they're there everywhere
um who are they the scouse the liver
pudlians who are they it sounds like
some sort of uh you know
gate p9477 is full of scouse we can't go
but Daniel Jackson's lost damn it I I
think the Unis has been working with the
scouts oh could yeah it could be yeah
yeah there's some scalcian Behavior
there yep but yeah no we've got we've
got names like that for people in
different parts of America so we got
scouses EastEnders
um
Texans Californians
Nevada nicknames for people that live in
parts of anywhere I don't know
dumbass
it's kind of very no it's kind of a like
nickname for States you know he's such a
Virginian well well because each one of
our stage is technically its own country
it's as big as a lot of countries
throughout the world so
it's it's he's Alaskan yeah yeah
you group things together it tends to be
like uh like the Midwest talks a certain
way yes that's a good one who she is
that makes sense
yeah
those are Ohio's Ohio folks okay so
there's um we have a city in this
country and we call the people that live
there geordies
where do you think that what what city
do you think that is geordies down maybe
the forge town no not the forge town
weirdly it's Newcastle upon town so the
people from our pet uh you're right pet
uh called geordies
no reason why all of our call centers
are based in Newcastle because um the
Geordie accent was considered one of the
least a sort of aggressive Accents in
the country so if you've got like a a
lady from Geordie and you're angry and
making a complaint and she's young
and start oh you like pets and start
like since you couldn't argue with it
and it's [__] true you can't argue
with the Jordy
I mean I think it was Robin Williams's
accent for Mrs Doubtfire wasn't it
she's supposed to be Scottish I'm
actually thinking about it
um but you got like glass region accent
is a nice aggressive accent that you've
ever heard and it seemed a bit like
Dublin the the northern Irish accent
it's just it's they just shout all the
time and I can't do it but it's they're
just straight all the time
um but anyway
um access is on Stately holds the right
to be its own country
and it's also in the Constitution
correct me if I'm wrong but it can
subdivide into its five different
countries we have we have five or six
different states that are immediate
uh-huh
within the state yes
Texas is bigger than like five or not
maybe 500 yeah it's bigger than if you
just put it anywhere in Europe it covers
most of Europe
yeah it is huge the only thing bigger
than Texas in America is Alaska and it's
pretty [__] big everything's bigger
in Texas
until you get to Alaska until you get to
Alaska
and Alaska will [__] kill you I think
Australia's bad for killing people
they haven't been to Alaska I've only
ever visited two places in my life that
I could go back year after year after
year after year but it's too expensive
of course and that would be Africa and
Alaska it's like the like the two
Frontiers left on this planet in a way
sure
besides like the entire continent and
Alaska
yes it's it's it's bad it's bad to rope
Africa as the continent but anywhere and
I'm doing it because I want to go
anywhere and everywhere
yeah I I've I've been to Africa a few
times and every time I come back it's
sort of like flush and talk that's a
great and that's literally all I think
but I went into some of the the
obviously because that's how it makes it
sound like Africa's is backwards there's
nations in Africa that are you know
amazing
um I had flush and water the entire town
it was nice
where I came back and was glad for
flushing toilets but I know I've been to
parts of Africa when you literally have
to squat and the the toilet was a hole
in the floor
yeah I was singing again no more singing
I don't know singing
stupid Star Trek radius
oh far away
yeah Harris is a traitor movement from
Texas how dare you not live in Texas
your entire life
we'll be back by 2030.
in the city city
California Texas
oh oh oh I live in an Evergreen Place
I'm from the swamp in Texas there's
always green it's East Texas I live in a
Pine Forest uh in a swamp uh
out here though there's not much green
but you know what I'm talking about I'm
talking about my lungs uh okay
you bless you with you
fun alternate lifestyle
alternate they call it California sober
okay California
I keep trying to tell my kids that you
know weed is bad and then I'm like they
got with a glass of wine in my hand like
we
need it is bad I'm like yeah it's really
I'm really a hypocrite but um thank you
Carrie for that really is dude
spot on
yeah yeah yeah yeah probably the Emojis
only work like half the time sometimes
they pop up and sometimes they don't
know
thank you I'm thinking a couple of
videos recently and I didn't I've not a
single comment about my either amazing
singing or terrible singing which must
mean I'm okay I'm going with okay but
I've not had even a comment like dear
God what were you doing
and my wife is always telling me I can't
sing with a [__] it sounds like well
that's her job thing for sure put me
down that's the job in it yeah she's not
supposed to build me up or or love me
and stuff you're supposed to put me down
and keep me in my place
only one necessary right
prevent me from going to karaoke because
every so often thinking I should do
karaoke so she um all right I should do
I should sing on a YouTube channel make
a YouTube channel on me sing it and she
just needs to remind me that that's
terrible idea karaoke track karaoke
oh we got a title
um I could just call it [__] Subspace
Rhapsody
and do a channel start singing Star Trek
just like I am singing I don't know why
I'm singing oh my God I can't stop
singing I should keep singing
force fields
those delicate little force fields oh no
or data song life forms wonderful little
life forms of life
um yeah that's also says yeah there's
always been music in Star Trek I should
do that more but not like that
you liked it you told me before the show
started I didn't like it I did I mean it
would have been better you know if it
was uh below decks but I really did like
it
yeah it would have been better for his
blowbacks
um I just ah God it was just bad
guns the Klingon bit when the Klingon
boy band bit people either found that
really really funny or made them
actually like Angry in their souls it
made me angry my soul
um I did the video it did it live and I
kept pausing the episode and doing a
little to camera a bit you know sort of
thing and and I it doesn't come across
how angry I am I was like I mean that
was just painful to watch I have to
stick my finger in my eyeball and swirl
it round to try and distract me what
I've just seen it really made me angry
but then a lot of trekkies have been
going oh and you keep you produce
yourself
your opinions to yourself Mr YouTuber
yeah that's all it's for is building you
know opinion it's a fountain opinions
here on YouTube that's the point of it
yeah and that you lovely people
occasionally tune in to my videos to
listen to my opinion that's the point
I'm not going to tell you your opinion
because that would be stupid that's a
different YouTube channel
yeah but I mean it's me either they're
going
you don't like oranges
20 quid
um
that I've just thought of another
YouTube channel we should do oh God SCI
fraud and how to plan to be a psychic
and then you send me money
um but no I I I hated I hated it
um
turn away and slam the door no I hate it
and I'm not afraid to tell people I hate
it but anyway and the Klingons boy band
was the best it wasn't your own so I'm
not here to tell you you're wrong or
right
um that it was stupid and embarrassing
and painful and I've already thought
stormy was wrong and uh because he
thought it was funny as well
yeah um but anyway guys
we didn't talk about what we were
supposed to at all
we touched on it live we touched it and
then we started talking about butt plugs
for 25 minutes
um
in chess
and Danny DeVito
there's no way
to know what you could get a thousand
monkeys type in a thousand typewriters
and and then not after a million years
not one of them would come out with in
this week's cytalk episode they're going
to start talking about paranormal end up
talking about Chester looks that now
why I love this love this channel so
much
who've known it who would have funked it
we did it
um to be fair the book was funny
but um
it's so good yeah real pain personally
every time
I love Allah
Jackson's characters was um some of the
best bits of the last book of Seasons
they're a perfect world for each other
and she wore a lot of leather quite big
boobs
um if Stargate were to do a musical Vala
and Adria that's it nobody else sings
um yeah Laura I'm so sorry it is two
weeks in a row
at least I'm not here for a few weeks
now
so we got two weeks of uh our brains
will have a little refreshing we're
we're powering down and rebooting and
we'll be back
we have to power down our butt plugs and
yes they ran out of battery um
if it's anything like my [__] I've
got one of those camera things on the
front door and it's got weird big AAA
batteries I can't find any so is it
going to be a bit like that if like book
plug batteries are they they're gonna
send they're gonna be some annoying
battery that you can't get hold of
um
I'm hoping if it's if it's fancy enough
to control from Far distances you just
plug that sucker in
I'm thinking it's a recharge are we
talking about my butt plugging now my um
my front door I think both
I've always thought you know what they
should do if they want to stop traffic
accidents because now my car
when I'm driving now it's got it it goes
the buses when I Veer off the roads like
wake me up
if it was a butt plug
you'd drive off the side of the road on
purpose and we know that's for true so
you've got this yeah
um
I'd concentrate more I have to admit
isn't bad if this brings another It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia episode of
mine I'll sure go right ahead we can't
get any worse at this point oh I don't
know I honestly I don't know if I should
say it online I mean it's it's actually
a we're already demonetized so let me
just go for it that's true okay so it's
been an earlier it's just become a
YouTuber thank you so much David
this conversation during this
conversation somehow some way there's
more about you David than it says
welcome
uh okay but the episode was like I want
to say it's like season six seven eight
or something they're on season 16. the
only bad season I think is the last
season and it wasn't even bad uh yeah no
wonder that's true
you're safe mate you're safe
you're all good uh as long as we can
make the Gopher laugh we're all set
right
um uh okay okay the episode though
that made me that you you reminded me of
uh Mack who is played by Rob mcelhaney
the guy that just bought rexham with uh
Ryan Reynolds he used to go but yeah his
character is
at the time closeted and is like oh I'm
not gay and it's like doing everything
super gay and is like oh I'm not I'm not
he's like I'm very Christian like I'm
super Catholic I'm doing all this stuff
and it's just like the doing it it's
really funny it's a running gag in the
show for like literally a decade and
it's hilarious uh and then they have a
really good episode with Danny DeVito
where he's kind of like I get it now and
it's just it's a funny thing uh but one
of the things that uh Mac was doing is
this character's name to try to
exercise and and keep himself from
sitting down
he he rigged a bicycle a little cycling
thing
that if if he was standing up it was
fine but if you try to sit down
a dildo shut out of the sea and uh that
that that is
yeah
[Music]
um
could you use a butt plug it's like
there's like a control thing so you know
like when you're working and you you're
busy and you've never got a third hand
sort of thing could you like get you're
probably one of those um for people that
are paraplegics and they have to sort of
like do stuff with their mouth when they
do it with their eyes and stuff and they
can then talk and like Stephen Hawking
did could they do it with a butt plug
so you squeeze it for like space bar or
you like wiggle about and you can get
the cursor to move the thing will that
work have we just scienced something
yeah no
um we haven't scienced anything and then
when you get text it vibrates so far
from sciency
is that what they're called are they
double 4A batteries is that what they're
called
quadruple a batteries are there
quadruple a batteries
AAA batteries
I need to find some Amazon don't sell
them and they they sold me the [__]
camera
stupid Amazon with a stupid camera
um anyway all right then guys as we've
wandered around the subject
are you sure
I think we're gonna call it a day
I know it's sad um we will be back in
three weeks ish
um
this was supposed to be a survival guide
to help you get through the strike and
the looming lack of entertainment
yeah well it's looking out of us are
writers I'm trying to write a book and
now I'm just going to be end up writing
bloody he's gonna be writing some smut
watch out
yeah
did you uh
oh did you ever start in on uh Dark
Shadows
nope
oh has always great content David really
thank you so much for the contribution
the poor guy
oh we're not even drunk
because we're sober
breakfast time over there yeah
I just had my own water and it was
raining weird stories
yeah
this is a Sci-Fi channel
yeah what we see
um
okay let's call it a day so that's an
hour and 40 minutes I'm gonna grab my
tea
um I don't need a wee I'm at least is
that at the end of the video
do it no I went halfway through
so I'm gonna send you a catheter for
Christmas yeah maybe this topic again
when we're back yeah maybe somebody in
the comments that's just the government
maybe we could try this again when we
come back it's like aliens on this
episode
it's just funny needed a laugh today
well we're glad and I tell you what I
mean there's there's not much better
than just coming on and talking [__]
with your mates oh it's so much fun I I
don't know how we got to this topic but
it wasn't very cathartic yeah I miss you
too Carrie
um but yeah we okay we're trying we're
trying the fun which is why I think the
videos are so much fun to do
so [__] it and and God knows there's no
other reasons so
um anyway guys we will see you in a
couple of weeks
um we even cheered Lee up
oh God
we are not Banning you God damn it
um while I'm away I am lining up a bunch
of videos they will drop
um mowing my look something will happen
in the news that will mean that they're
old by the time I get into but I'm doing
my best so I've done a bit of an update
on a couple of things like Babylon 5 and
the expanse and a couple other things
just stuff that I've heard over the last
few weeks and so they're all lined up
and they'll be dropping while I'm away
but um I will be on a cruise ship
heading down towards the um the the the
the ocean
you live on an island adjacent
I live on quite a Big Island an island
I'm still I I hate a man no I don't like
I don't like the ocean I'm scared of
water I can't swim I'm a rubbish swimmer
so I've always been I remember I was uh
I was in the military back in the day
and I got this
well you know more Royal Marines or was
it the orange in the Army
um but the uh my CEO came over and went
um I've Got This brilliant training
opportunity for you
um it's gonna go do some training with
the Royal Marines I was just like cops
can you go and have a look at my jacket
first and then come back to me so we
went and had a look at my thing and when
you do your basic you have to be able to
swim three lengths and you get three
attempts I failed twice
um and I just about managed it on the
third time or I would have been kicked
out
um so we came back and went parachute
jumping you're gonna go do parachute
jumping can't try and doing that
um yeah I broke my back instead so
but yeah can't swim for [__] I swim like
a brick
always happen
um only people who live in Britain think
it's a big island
Australians think Australia is a bigger
island and Greenland's a bit bigger I
suppose but it's quite a Bitcoin you
melt it I think everyone's gonna be
there even if it's then it's pointer it
takes like three days to walk across it
there are farms in Australia that or
Texas take longer than that to walk
across
that is true that is true king ranch
immediately comes to mind yeah I will be
going down to the Tenerife and all those
on my nice Cruise so if I can I will
send you some little Sunny off-the-ship
videos but I don't think I'm gonna have
the Wi-Fi but you never know but anyway
I'm just I'm and you know what's going
to happen within two or three days of me
going on this Cruise where I can't
access the internet
will not call but what is almost
certainly going to get announced
let's start again
you know it's gonna happen there will be
an official announcement on Stargate the
second I get on that damn boat and
you'll be digging off in the water
perfect phrasal
I I will I will take things yes just not
while you're digging off of the water
please
um we find out that Australia is a
continent yes all right it's a continent
um
yes uh the 15th is coming so it will be
waiting for me the road home will be
waiting for me when I get back I will
watch it I will do a video on it as soon
as I and then I will give it away and as
stormy's got bored we'll go now so
I I figured out how to do something
oh okay shall we give them a treat
everybody
it's not the fanciest thing in the world
but it it it it it it's very fun uh this
is our first trailer for getaway the
movie
[Music]
can you hear it yep
Amazing Grace
[Music]
is that an evil
dolls possessed
hello
cross possessed
[Music]
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
the chicken got her boobs and then went
dipping because I'm pretty sure that's a
horror movie rule again in it
she forgets boobs out
[Music]
that's that the music
very cool that looks amazing
um have you guys heard have you guys
heard of this new thing on Netflix
another three body problem I just saw a
trailer for it yesterday and it's like
what the hell is this
it's not sci-fi not movement a Japanese
or Chinese sci-fi
cost a fortune to make
it's the Game of Thrones guys DB Weiss
and uh uh
David it's not okay so it's not George
no no no no no no
I believe it was written by chick chick
Shin Liu I don't I think that's how you
say the name I'm not positive
uh but I think chick Shin Liu had like
some creative input with it too so it's
like the Creator along with him which is
When the Game of Thrones guys work at
their best whenever they're they have
actual like things to adapt from so
what is it a movie or is it a series
isn't that thing I believe I believe
yeah they're limited limited series I
think yeah well it's got to be because
they're show Runners they don't really
like direct films anything like that
they're showrunners so yeah
so let's wait and see we'll see let's
see what they do but yes man very cool
thank you for sharing that um
and the movie comes out and I'm not
going to watch it but somebody will and
so I don't really like horror movies I
don't think it'll be scary enough to not
watch it's more of a thriller
through
you'd be surprised how how a little bit
I find movies and I wouldn't watch it so
now I will be watching it of course I
will and then we will be hey we'll and
you've got you've already got seven or
eight people watching the stream that
are desperate to watch it now as well so
um good on you man I'll tell you what
hey yeah how many of us I I'm am I the
only person on tier that hasn't made a
film
it's just me yeah
because Matt's done a little old stuff
huh I thought so yeah but Matthew's
films at home though don't count
they they don't I mean I've done that
type of film and they don't count but um
I made films when I was a kid I made the
wheelie bin murders that was my first
epic
um movie
um it was a bunch of and you know why I
may call it really been murdered because
a man had been murdered and Duncan have
wheelie been locally
we did the wheelie bin man
yeah yeah my parents didn't think that
was all of that in bad taste okay and um
and then we had the guy that defeated
the wheelie bin murderer we had an epic
training montage
so bad it's only about 12 or something
no you gotta put that on here so I can
watch it
no fortunately it was done on a mate it
was a Japanese kid who had who had a
camcorders you only want to have a
camcorder so he did it and made it and I
don't know where it is it's still
somewhere
I make YouTube videos that counts right
civilization
that's right and my health safety Guy
videos they're they're that's acting I
have to act in those hey we did a whole
scene earlier this morning that was fun
yeah we we and at the end of it I went
see
ing I'm just perfect and so yes we do
have a um a movie coming out where me
and Harris act together oh my God that
comes out so um HR guy is in the house
oh my gosh I can't wait I love HR guy
you've never met him before you know you
don't know Hedgehog he's new he's a new
character I invented
so health and safety guy will be back
because he's going to Atlantis soon so
health is safe to go back
um
if you're going to Atlantis on the
cruise ship is that is that where he's
going now he might he might do some I
might do something tomorrow and so it
might be out this week you know take a
snag like 10 minutes you know on you
know on the uh the cruise ship going you
know that's now touring Atlantis that
planet you know
I can record it well on the answer
somebody I'm doing it let's record it
edit it later just get it'll just get
plenty that and plenty of b-roll and
but
hey mate that's been brilliant idea all
right come on guys I've got we've been
we've been procrastinating now for 15
minutes yeah and popcorn power and Lee
Wilcox real fast
why what have they said now
um they go off each other very well go
the first one this channel is cut
channels and gaming channels and banned
from all of them this is the breath of
fresh air for me sci-fi and porn we
didn't did we did we talk about porn oh
we did a little bit I suppose
we're rearing up next to it
didn't somebody already make that movie
thank God I'm locked out of the title
you're producing it don't worry oh okay
foreign
it's not going to film itself is it
stormy
all right for your close-up
one more but look
and we're out of here
guys thank you so much as always say bye
everybody toodles
[Music]
purposely haven't ended it just so we
could do that
what plug lava lamp